why are you now Francois sait orange
asks why are you no hiding the amount
you receive from patreon I found it very
motivating to see the amount skyrocket
and felt glad to be part of this as if
you were an artist I now feel more like
I'm buying a product and I find it less
appealing
yeah well it's one of those things where
I'm kind of damned if I do and damned if
I don't you know and I don't know what's
correct I guess I probably got tired of
the sort of more left-leaning let's say
radical left-leaning press people
jumping up and down on me every chance
they got because people were donating
money for for services that is
particularly rent you know that I render
essentially for free
you know I there must have been 10
articles in the last week following the
Lindsay Shepard incident pointing out
that I'm somehow being manipulative and
and evil in a capitalist sort of way for
daring to allow people to donate money
to help support what I'm doing and it
gets kind of tiring and so I don't know
I just and I guess I also thought that
maybe there's a part of it that's like
well I wouldn't exactly call it bragging
but because it's not but that's about
good enough I mean it was an appeal to
privacy I suppose in part to I don't
know if it's the right thing I could do
a poll on Twitter and find out I guess I
did that for some other things this week
so anyways that's that's the answer to
that